it was a gloomy October morning a man
and his two sons went fishing in the
woods that stretched miles beyond their
own backyard
his wife watched from the kitchen window
as they disappeared into the trees hours
passed and the wife began to worry she
had not heard from her family since they
had left in the morning the dinner she
had prepared for them had gone cold
after another hour of waiting she
decided to go out and look for them by
now it was almost completely dark she
ran through the woods calling out their
names but there was no reply it was some
time before she came across a stream but
there lay the bodies of her husband and
oldest son with a knife stuck in each
one of their chests it was obvious that
they had been murdered she continued to
look for her youngest son surely an 11
year old boy could not survive alone in
the woods for long it was too dark and
she could not see anything after morning
her husband and son she decided to head
back home she now realized that the
person who killed her two family members
was still out there in the woods
terrified out of her wits
she ran frantically through the woods
until she reached her home when she
arrived she told her neighbor what had
happened but swore her to secrecy as she
did not want the events of today to be
known by anyone else the next day her
neighbor helped her smuggle the bodies
out of the stream and together they
buried them both in the woods the woman
was still in search of her youngest son
she had searched the woods the entire
morning and found no trace of him she
hoped he had found shelter and would
return to her when he knew it was safe
she had been digging her husband's and
son's grave all day and she was
exhausted from the work when she had
finished digging her neighbor offered to
go back into the house and retrieve two
blankets in order to wrap their bodies
the woman agreed and suggested that she
took them from her bed nearly 3/4 of an
hour had passed and the neighbor had
still not returned
the woman decided to go back to see if
her neighbor was okay as she arrived she
began to climb her stairs she opened her
bedroom door and was horrified at the
sight she screamed for there on her bed
near the open window was the severed
head of her youngest son and a knife the
neighbor nowhere to be found
if you've enjoyed this video then please
go ahead and leave it a like consider
subscribing if folklore mythology is
something that interests you if you have
anything you'd like to discuss or have
any ideas for future videos then please
go ahead and let me know in the comments
below as always I've been your host
mythology and folklore explained